we love the sack Awards because it's
actors voting for actors in a room where
you get to run into people like Michael
Imperioli
how cool is that very cool very cool so
um obviously you know the time said the
severance is one of the best shows new
shows of the year does that add any
pressure going into the second season
are you guys just ready to fly I think
we
think we have second season just because
really
aliens were really invested and we don't
want to let them down so I think they
the pressure is more from them than
anything because I will say man this is
the longest I've had to wait for a
cliffhanger you know there was a big one
at the end of the first season so I'm
like dying to get it are we any closer
to season two reaching our screens not
really no we are a little closer we have
shooting for several months but we still
have a ways to go yeah now are you
hitting her up for any scoop too are you
like trying to figure out hitting up her
for any scoop no no I want no spoilers
until it's done no I can't yeah yeah no
he I have to suffer in silence so when
the new season does drop do you guys
watch it together do you invite people
into a watch party no I think that's
like really corny like let's watch me
come over yeah no I'm not into that you
know I've always kind of tried to
minimize you know me being an actor and
my kids life and all of that I love my
work I'm proud of it I love the projects
I've been a part of but I yeah I'm Gonna
Keep it in perspective speaking of all
those amazing projects you've been a
part of there's a couple of movie
anniversaries coming up including the
30th anniversary of True Romance this
year how's that make you feel very old
it makes me feel like wow that was like
yesterday and it and it makes me feel
grateful because Tony Scott our director
passed away several years ago and he was
so pivotal to me as an actress he
listened to every idea I had he always
was like that's a great idea Bama Bama's
got an idea let's do this and you really
taught me to listen to my instincts he
was kind of like
a great girl dad
30 years ago that's something special
then because I feel like the times were
different then than they are now they're
exactly exactly right and it really gave
me strength to work with uh directors
after that say no no no no you know what
I do have a good idea yeah
and real quick because we're fans of the
movies movie Holes it's turning 20.
remember you're in holes I do yes I do
kissing Kate Barlow I know
I know that was a blast actually and and
that director was great too Andy what a
sweetheart and I'm terrible horse rider
so I always fall off horses and I told
them I said listen I always follow
forces and all the old Cowboys are like
not with me I'm gonna teach you little
lady how to ride this one
okay maybe you can't be done
foreign